[Musique]
c'est la rentrée de la classe biberon au
football-club d'argentan premier
entraînement de la saison première
inscription aussi pour certaines mais
aux footballeurs en herbe venus
d'horizons bien lointain grande partie
d'accord tu as joué avant non la page
avant donc là c'est sort de la douche
s'il croit pas trop beau et jaloux club
phocéen sait déjà c'est parce que on
passe quand même de la lauze donc
puisque danse africaine genre donc là on
arrête tout et on passait un fauteuil et
c'est vraiment ce que j'espère nîmes a
big n
[Musique]
ou bien inscrire notre grande marine
dont 111 féminine
il ya une motivation particulière de la
part de votre fille qui vous a demandé
où c'est vous qui avez décidé parce que
je sauve au foot avec les copains à
l'école du couvent à j'avais envie de
en faire comme ça avant tu faisais notre
sport dur là bonjour marine tu me fais
un bisou va bien donc c'est la première
fois que je te vois moi d'accord tu vas
faire un essai aujourd'hui mais je
comptais archi motivés
vous l'aurez donc bien compris un vent
nouveau souffle sur le terrain de
football mais content de reprendre le
foot et au petit jeu du ballon rond
les filles se démarque par le nombre
croissant d'entre elles qui gagne les
rangs des clubs alors le ballon doit
bien rester à côté de ton pied ou tard
on a passé un été très mouvementée avec
beaucoup de contacts chez les petites
la médiatisation de la coupe du monde
féminine a fait beaucoup de bien et puis
bah c'est vrai que là depuis trois ans
que l'on que l'on a développé ce projet
là ça ne fait qu augmenter chaque année
argentan c'est une école sont pour son
féminine où la mixité a également sa
place selon la catégorie d'âge menée
depuis trois ans ce projet s'inscrit
bien sûr dans le temps et le temps
justement il est au changement
elles ont la chance ces jeunes filles
qu'il y ait vraiment un espace pour elle
parce que malheureusement dans le passé
iata pas toujours été le cas et
certaines filles ont été des fois tout
seul dans un club de foot tout seul à
s'entraîner uniquement avec des garçons
donc voila c'était un peu compliqué pour
elle mais la voilà il ya beaucoup de
filles qui sont motivés puis un espace
pour elle et joue entre filles elles
vont jouer contre des autres filles en
championnat à voir en plateau et donc
c'est ce qui les attire aujourd'hui à
l'école des filles du foot
les mamans gagne aussi leur place sur
les terrains dirigeante éducatrice ou
animatrice elles sont une dizaine de
bénévoles cette année
ce sera menée là un jour pourquoi
c'était plus massage était vraiment
ciblé sur foot masculin fhm masculin
piva j'ai déjà autre france est aussi
intéressant pour les filles et c'était
tout à fait pareil sur la planète tout
et 1001 argentan le temps se conjugue à
présent au champ des possibles
on entend encore des réflexions sexistes
etc
mais bon là pour l'instant ce sont
encore plus forte parce qu'on a envie de
faire notter notre football et ce qui se
passe aussi c'est que les filles
aujourd'hui en place aussi dans la cour
d'école
elles ont une place dans la cour d'école
et puis elles ont envie vraiment dossier
de s'émanciper choisir une activité que
ce soit une activité 10,1 un peu
masculine
qu'on se le dise les cours de foot à la
récré ne sont plus seulement réservé aux
garçons nous verrons d'ailleurs qu'au
collège rostand argentan les filles ont
pris une sérieuse option
[Musique]